then swings on these studios in the
heart of Los Angeles this is screen
junkies movie finds now your host Andy
signor today's episode is brought to you
by America's best unlimited network
don't miss a show with unlimited data
from t-mobile
Thanks epic movie voice what the crap
I'm not Andy signor I'm Hal Rudnick you
guys thanks for joining us on movie
fights live we have some epic fights
some great fighters some first-time
fighter and man so much good stuff is
going to be happening today some of the
great fights we've got include who'd be
your worst choice to play James Bond
what's the best comedy of the decade so
far and which movie character would have
the best Instagram account if you'd like
to join the conversation live on Twitter
go to hashtag movie fights live alright
and let's meet today's combatants first
he's been on TV fights and all over
screen junkies it's DJ Woolridge DJ oh
that's me have you done anything to prep
for today's fight not enough okay we
shall see once the battle commences
second he's a fan favorite fighter who
hopefully won't have a nosebleed this
time around it's brett erlich yes you do
have a nosebleed actually you know was
and that nosebleed was a product of all
the cocaine you did to get jacked up for
movie for you right I've done I've done
more today so maybe we'll get a double
nostril leakage you are so jacked up
movie bites I I did I did some prep
myself but I ripped it in half with my
cocaine strength oh man
this is the opposite of my preparation I
did too much it means I'm gonna lose
again and I've never won there's no drug
testing here on movie fights and this
man has been taking HGH for weeks in
preparation and he's making his movie
fights debut he's a writer super funny
comedian actor what don't you do it's
Darian sills Evans I don't know I don't
do dishes okay yeah do I dishes glasses
oh I once moved out of apartment
apartment and had a sink full of dirty
dishes for like a year and I just
decided I'm just throwing all the dishes
away
yeah sometimes you got to over right
there he's gonna be fact-checking
holding it down on the couch lawn Harris
oh yeah it's perfectly phrased it's
you're looking really good man you
should feel good about it thanks guys I
appreciate it and sitting there right
next to lon sir introduce yourself to us
hi I'm Alex I'm from Irvine I've been a
huge fan of the show for just about
three years now
yeah I've seen almost every single
episode so it's a very kind of surreal
to be here
dreams do come since you've seen every
show just to give me your top 10 movie
fights memories right now just kidding I
was glad to have you thanks for being
there buddy making the drive up from
Irvine oh yeah
welcome back to California geography
talk about five freeway treated so as
far as the rules
quick reminder all scoring is based on
facts presented passion and creativity
I'm having the worst time in the world
picking out which camera is on right now
but you know we'll get that in sync
right JT look for the red light every
time I look up and it's like I look at
the wrong one than the red light okay
you know what we're gonna go with the
flow I think by the end of the show
we'll get this right and lon anything
anything else Eddie Eddie facts to check
yet we just found it facts check yet
you're doing a great job so far that's
the only fact I know all right you know
what what do you say we get this thing
fired up jte roll it
at the time
the taillights
work it really got the juices flowing
our first question gentlemen besides is
fast and furious
besides fast and furious what earthbound
franchise should go to space ok and DJ
oh we're gonna start with you
congratulations to me so I was thinking
you know obviously your brain you say
with not faster fury Sabrina really goes
all the craziest franchises out and I
was like no that's the bait don't take
it so I went with a movie that actually
thought would legitimately benefit from
a space setting something that is
already tangentially connected to the
space and so I went with men in black
alright so men in black follows the
story of two gentlemen that are trying
to defend the Earth from aliens that are
living undercover on the planet so what
happens if what was this with would this
be the fourth movie what would happen if
they have to go to a space station off
planet completely inhabited by aliens
they're the ones undercover there now
both the fish-out-of-water because let's
be honest after one of the things that
we all loved about men in black one is
Will Smith kind of getting used to the
rules in the world and they've always
tried to recapture that to varying
degrees of success but now both agents
would be a fish out of water in an alien
inhabited world also what's the other
best part of the men in black movies
when you see all the aliens interacting
you see all the different cultures all
the different world and so now you have
these two kick-ass agents up in space
trying to deal with world where they are
the only two humans there got it men and
black in space Brett what do you got I
decided to go with a franchise did you
haven't heard from in a while one that
isn't crazy one that needs to be
revitalized one that and that one is
something that could be awesome in space
and it's probably a little obvious but
home alone so a home alone is this we're
going to take a distant into distantly
into the future this is a we've done
permutations of it on earth but the one
place where I think it can be best
served is by taking it into the future
where Kevin McCallister the ninth
is on a big Space Station and it's space
Christmas and they founded the space
alarm and his family has to evacuate
from this space station it's essentially
a space crews and they evacuating they
get sent off but guess who gets left
behind Kevin McCallister this whatever
number I said earlier ninth ninth Kevin
McCallister the ninth and so we have the
world's it turns out that that alarm was
a false alarm
and it was tripped by these the you know
hapless space alien criminals we get a
little of the taste of the men in black
aliens but they are a team of the
dumbest space aliens and so it is a
super fun romp as he protects not just
his house which is in this case his
space cruise bunk but also all the cool
space cruise type places on this space
cruise and it's amazing guys you're
gonna see it when I get it done I'm just
gonna laugh and laugh but also at the
end you're gonna be like family is
important and that's my answer family is
important home alone in space okay and
Darian Wow
you guys pick such great franchises I
got a new franchise fresh everyone loves
them Keanu John wick John wick and space
what's so funny about that I think the
world is ready for that
in the first John wick sleeper hit he's
just a badass you know assassin who
what's a revenge for his dead dog second
John wick the world's opened up you have
these little gold coins and it buys you
anything from women to hotel rooms to
doctors to maybe space vessels you don't
know we don't know third John wick could
be a whole man in black crossover [ __ ]
we don't know maybe the assassins know
some other otherworldly [ __ ] and they
send John wick who now has to get
revenge on some other guy who stole his
alien dog
I maybe finds an alien dog at the end
and brings him to earth that'd be cute
okay John wick in space great gentlemen
mix it up fight I gotta be
with you John wick is one of my favorite
movies of all time I love both of those
movies so so immediately I want to be on
board with your pick yeah but I think
part of what benefits it is the the it
goes deeper into its own mythology and
set this world of assassins I feel like
if you introduced space you completely
throw it off from what makes it special
what makes how does it become
unrealistic tiffypop spaces unrealistic
I'm saying I'm saying distracts from
what makes those movies special man what
makes them sing yeah I mean right I feel
like what I what I like about the John
wick motivations in his movies are like
very home earth comforts like his car
and his dog and I did write down you you
seem to like this idea but I did write
down somewhere along the crease here
though was like it's just it's I think
space is gonna ruin this franchise maybe
it needs to go through the kinds of
terrible terrible sequels that we saw
was saying well I'm home alone before we
lift it up because it's gonna be John
wick in space I think we can have more
different mafia worlds collide and all
that and I like it it doesn't have to be
John wick 3 it could be like John wick
12 I mean Keanu Reeves doesn't age it's
true he does not age age he can play
John wick right into a new space age for
us
I would like to transition at home alone
a little bit because that's another one
where like part of what makes homeland
special another movie I love again I
want to side with you but part works
especially if you feel like you could be
that kid you feel like you could make
those inventions you feel like you could
make traps that would probably kill
actual burglars in the real world and if
you take down the space that
relatability goes away no because the
themes are all there don't you see we
have movies set in space all the time
and those movies set in space look at
guardians of the galaxy the theme is
even though his father is a planet
spoiler the theme is just father-son
relationships so you can still bring
those themes into something sci-fi plus
you get like really cool space gadgets
and like funny slapstick space alien
friends yeah the ball is a child like
none of that's part of the way I grew up
now it could just be any space movie by
the way I wish we always did spoilers
after like Rose but as the sled spoilers
and all right you just ruined it now I
get it that was wrong of me
he's a slam I'm just gonna be hilarious
I mean I could see it maybe as a reboot
I take their side a little bit on it I'd
like to see it I don't know even it's a
reboot because again like what you gotta
think about what makes the movie special
with men in black like aliens already
part of the formula the
fish-out-of-water is already part of
what makes it work by taking to space it
emphasizes the things that already make
that movie work I don't need it I don't
need another men in black
you know I the world doesn't know what
it doesn't want it no one has asked
close a connection to really either of
those movies in the way that will really
vibe with the the children who are gonna
go see it and the parents who are going
to kind of nostalgic LIGO like yeah what
this is my future and my past at the
same time do you think that I'm like
sleeper generation of home alone fans
they're like 10 now right but you're
saying you're talking about the dynamic
when people say make something for the
kids and something for the adults there
is something for the adults in here I
just don't I don't need to see this the
outer space version of men in black but
I need to see the outer space version of
Kevin McCallister and the more I think
of the time and how much we'll need to
create space cruises maybe the tenth can
throw some questions at you guys
Brett I'm gonna ask you who's who's the
cast of your home alone in space alright
so here's what's great we have a full-on
CGI alien played by Joe Pesci okay he's
back he's there he's in it Marv is
actually the same Marv who got frozen in
ice as part of an experimental prison
treatment and is then bought out so we
have Daniel Stern and Joe Pesci and then
along the way we have the stars of today
we're craving we have the like rebel
Wilson's we have the you know Kristin
Wiggs we have the I don't know Ellie
Kemper is the people who have been made
stars by now because of great movies
that they've made in this last decade oh
and is it Macaulay Culkin did you say
yeah Macaulay Culkin is there oh is he
Kevin McCallister the ninth so Luther
Kevin McCallister they're not having
McCallister the ninth is an a fresh face
we don't know yet
who definitely has the same number of
potentially famous siblings as Macaulay
Culkin did back then gotcha
Darien I'd like you to break down the
plot of John wick and space a little bit
more for us okay John wick in space an
asteroid is coming the Hitmen coalition
have the money to get off the planet it
rips off every other movie has twenty
twelve minutes it has a little peppered
with everything there's an arc full of
hitmen that is gonna leave and John wick
has his gold right but then someone says
hey John
before you go I need you to get revenge
on this other guy and he misses the arc
I don't know I haven't really thought it
out I was gonna ask for some help
the ideas guy to writers I'm sure I just
come up with the concept I find funding
for these guys I just want to see the
movie I can bash it into existence I
wasn't gonna write it right huh I mean I
like watching Karen do anything so agree
there's something there and then men and
men in black in space
tell me a little bit about who about the
plot and who they be squaring off
against are there any guest stars
playing villains I would have you what
you probably have is somebody on earth
is murdered and in the first act they're
trying to figure out who it is and they
discover that it's an alien that is now
offworld and so they're gonna have to go
offworld to figure it out and there's a
Space Station
that is kind of like the weigh station
because they describe earth as the
Casablanca of Otherworld so this is the
way station for aliens get to earth it's
completely inhabited by aliens and
that's where the murder mystery is
solved so you've got a little bit of a
Chinatown vibe but like more fun where
you're in the heat of it you're
surrounded by enemies but you've got
weird versions of our society our
culture people running shops societies
politicians yeah what are a li
politicians like how do aliens coexist
these are things that we've barely
tapped into in these movies and they
have to unravel it as they go deeper and
deeper into this whole society remember
in Star Wars rogue one where they're on
the planet with full of criminals it's
like a sir I think that but with a
minute black they're your enemy and so
they're trying to figure that out and
you
men in black is you could have all sorts
of people come in and do guest row you
you actually want to have your moving
people coming in and doing little guest
roles in occasional celebrity like they
did on the on the wall where he's like
hey these celebrities aliens maybe one
of them is in the weigh station to pick
up a family member you know what I mean
like Bieber Bieber would be a great
example of somebody that's clearly
innate alien I would throw a Tommy
Wiseau in there because I legitimately
think he's an alien I really do who else
I mean the movie you could even have
Michael B Jordan training up to be a new
agent in in the men in black and have to
be thrust into this like sink or swim
situation gotcha
all right let's start with Brett final
thoughts final thoughts for me is I'm
thinking about what you've pitched for
this man and black thing and it just
seems like you know I want to see other
space movies it just seems like we got
the conventional alien thing and it's
we're out there trying to find like the
bad guy in space and we've kind of I've
seen that you know and then with John
wick I feel like we're taking a beloved
franchise that's in its prime and we're
ruining it by adding space you want to
wait till that franchises died bring it
back from the dead in a way that
involves space that's what space is for
it is the future of society when we've
ruined our planet and it's the future of
home alone when they've ruined that
franchise excellent thank you sir
Darrien final thoughts uh you know I I
have to say am i John wick argument is
pretty flimsy
[Laughter]
keep going the more I listen to you too
you know DJ I kind of want to see that
men in black Navy now I'm sorry I mean I
appreciate it because because men in
black is a failing franchise it is any
chance to save it it's not gonna be to
merge it with their you know 21 22
let's try to get back to ya and you know
I'm sorry but home alone in space would
be like direct to your heart no all
right
Darien using his final thoughts to throw
his guy trying DJ closing I you know
again with both John wick and home alone
I feel like putting them in space
berries what makes those franchises
special it makes them nostalgic or not
in a John wicks case but in home Alone's
case what the parts that you've liked
about it growing up if you throw it in
space you lose that because home alone
it's all about being in your home it's
it's tougher to imagine being in a space
station it's it's a more home-based
fantasy well others
I wish I wrote it's actually if you have
dumb aliens it becomes a great version
of not even kidding it's right there
yeah but with men in black if you take
it in space if you kind of do the behind
enemy lines version of it emphasizes the
things that we liked about the franchise
fish-out-of-water strange new worlds new
situations by putting in space it
actually gives you an opportunity to
remind yourself and to capture and
emphasize the things that make those
movies great alright quite a battle
quite a collision between the
unstoppable force the immovable object
and one other thing that's equally as
impressive
so Darien you pulled the ripcord on on
the last I had okay
have you know children who might see
this someday yes but a potentially good
move for the franchise one day but not
today
so it came down to DJ and Brett and DJ
thought it might have been a little on
the nose to put men in black and space
Brett you you came with I love that you
included Joe Pesci I love that you
included Daniel Stern as the Wet Bandits
were coming back but then you lost me a
little bit when you did not include
Macaulay Culkin as Kevin McCallister and
you didn't have an equal replacement on
deck for him because man that Culkin
factor oh I mean that's a lot he's the
hologram in the spaceship that's it
that's a huge gamble that you're gonna
find someone as charismatic and then DJ
coming in with that force awakens or was
it the rogue one or the rug one
reference I that really made it a vivid
idea of these guys behind enemy lines
and the more you were selling that the
more I started to get on board and you
know what that's the movie I want to see
DJ you get the point
[Applause]
[Music]
Juan Harris where'd they screw up really
not not a lot of facts a check we got a
lot of suggestions from the fans that
wouldn't work though we got James Bond
sharknado predator all have already been
to space guys come on the other fact
that we check family is important
suggested by the audience the number one
most suggested franchise that you moved
to space surprising to me pirates we got
a lot of suggestions the Pirates of the
Caribbean should go to the great sea in
the sky also a lot of people suggested
face off and a Reinhard had the perfect
title space off that's pretty prize at
that happening right now the fan poll
they did agree with you yeah 65 percent
on YouTube went for DJ and the men in
black pitch 52 percent on Twitter both
won both 26% on Twitter for John wick
22% for home alone you don't want to be
good again you know yeah I'm with ya
alright man quite a first for a token
would make a fantastic alien and men in
black alright I get 10% crossover we
might be brokering a major deal here all
right next up round 2
what movie character what fictional
character or maybe not fictional maybe
it'll be from a documentary would have
the best Instagram account
what movie character would have the best
Instagram account and we're gonna start
with Brett alright the answer to this
question unequivocally is Ava from ex
machina why she has not only the
qualities of but the abilities of what
it takes to make an amazing Instagram
first of all she's a good-looking lady
and not just in like the sports model
way but in this very like approachable
internet lovable like cute innocent way
and then I think what really puts it
over the top for me is she has the
uncanny ability to as we saw in the
movie spoiler alert sort of to go
through everything that's ever been done
online at the same time figure
what works and through that algorithm
deduce what will draw you in and make
you love it not because she's you know
inherently manipulative inherently good
or bad but just because she can and she
will answer that the fact that she is
out in the world
she got all this success by manipulating
like a nerdy tech person so someone who
is you know internet savvy and then add
to that she's seeing everything for the
first time and she is able to relate
that to you in new fresh ways I think
that is the absolute best Instagram
possible plus tech tips because she's
inside the internet gotcha
Ava from ex machina Darion talk to us I
think this is easy this is really easy
there's only one character who'd be made
for Instagram today just she's just a
little behind the curve and that's Nomi
Malone from showgirls if there was ever
an Instagram star in the making it would
be no me she wouldn't even have to take
off her clothes that much she would just
wear little string bikinis she'd have 4
million followers and then she convert
that into more stardom and have 20
million followers she would be an
Instagram superstar hands down all
because she wants to be a star
alright Elizabeth Berkeley's Nomi Malone
showgirls from Darian thank you oops
false alarm and DJ yeah you wanted
somebody that's gonna give you nice
quality pictures give you a nice variety
of pictures show you things you've never
seen before that's why you follow
somebody on Instagram so I recommended
Peter Parker the spider-man because not
only is he a photographer also
incredibly talented of taking pictures
of himself master of the selfie makes
money off of it but he can also show you
things you've never seen those stomp
pics where they're hanging off a
building that's his day-to-day but he
can also go around the world he can
shave we saw in spider-man homecoming he
had that video
the fight at the airport that's on his
Instagram and have you seen stuff like
that no not only that he was gonna take
us to space in infinity war he is all
over literally any place you would want
pictures that boy was gonna be that boy
snapping pics not only that hanging out
with some of the most beautiful people
in the world
several of them are named Chris all
right but but the most attractive people
on the planet are his BFFs and there
also are superheroes and supervillains
and so you get the wide breadth of
everything you would could possibly want
to see on an Instagram account all right
fellas mix it up what are you talking
about everyone would know who he is
instantly no usually not the spider-man
account you're hanging out with for how
long would it take for it to be what no
I'm sorry I just with you yeah how long
would it take for it to be hacked
spider-man exposed Aunt May dead here's
my problem with spider-man it's he has
to make that decision in a Peter Parker
or not and guess what if you want those
like aerial photos he's gonna have to be
spider-man he's gonna be having the same
face in every photo cuz it's a mask yeah
but if you don't get those micro
expressions that Ava is so good at
doesn't give a [ __ ] about people her
humanity the one person that's why
that's why Nomi beats Ava because Ava
would you know look at someone like Nomi
and say oh this is a perfect Instagram
let me emulate this well she would do
that but also every other show girl
who's ever existed she's been able to go
through evaluate what works which I hate
no average little girl is not crimped
hair and high hip lines by the way that
was what was hot nineties oh so I don't
know it depends on I didn't see the new
spider-man sorry it was like a protest
vote cuz I didn't win when I said that
would be the biggest movie of the summer
in our movie fights last night but he
works for a newspaper that's old media
you think he's gonna be able to conquer
new media this way no it's a man like
people see like oh this is odd
fate also if it's on Instagram you're
trying to talk about his like flying
through the air thing Instagram has a
decidedly worse image stabiliser then
snapchat so let's snapchat maybe are you
entertaining you can't take his pictures
and upload them to Instagram okay here's
the answer that's better than that you
want all these aerial photos Ava buys a
drone but see Ava it was too interested
in murdering humanity she's team up with
Skynet anybody know but she's not doing
Instagram that's why would even really
want to do Instagram why would she care
if people follow her because well it's
seven why would she need to continue to
entertain them find herself in some kind
of here's all I gotta say here's all I
gotta say you think you ever pegged you
think you never pegged but the
characters in that movie sure thought
they had her pegged and guess what they
were wrong you're wrong here's an idea
she loves me I love her no but see
that's the mistake they made they
thought she behaved like a human in an
tree yeah but she just murdered
everybody like terminator she's
basically terminator I feel like I'm
winning in this place everything's
against me so hard they know it they
know I'm against both of you because of
the ever ridiculous arguments Nomi is
the queen of Instagram also all that Ava
would have to do is charm Peter Parker
which let's face it will be pretty easy
he's a little insecure and say can I fly
with you on those spider-man things and
he in a heartbeat would be taking her
around so she could have all the
presidential team-up of Ultron you have
to stop her like like Peter's a young
hip kid he know he knows what's what
happens when you're spider-man gets five
million Instagram followers and then you
know the corporation's come knocking at
his door and say hey spider-man can you
wear you know a logo on your suit do it
Creed 4-0
he's already teamed up with Tony Stark
he said this money's already sold out
also you want to say that he has all
these access to these locations that no
one ever has but there's a cystogram
spot called instagram account called you
did not sleep there uh-huh
that shows everyone who pretends to have
these really awesome views from the
places that they went but it turns out
that it's all completely fake yeah but
you don't do that because this person
can actually climb up walls yeah but it
doesn't matter you don't have to go all
those places his skill is completely
unnecessary because you can fake it what
do you then be rendered useless as a
superhero that's like taking you know 10
Instagram post a day because that's like
how many instrument' posted how many
photos do you take to get one gentleman
a lot of persuasive arguments happening
right here at this table but I'm gonna
throw a question out to everyone I want
you to walk me through three Instagram
posts what three visual Instagram posts
would look like paint a picture in my
mind's eye Brett you let off so we will
start with you three Instagram posts
they're gonna run the gamut here's a
fact that beautiful women on Instagram
appeal to two different kinds of people
one the boys who follow them who think
that they're super hot and to the women
who are looking for lifestyle tips now
someone who has studied nothing but
lifestyle tips and is able to give them
adequately Ava
oh here's the dress of the day this is
the cute little dress that'll make the
boys fall in love with you in addition
it is the oh I was this face a second
ago I just pulled it off another model
boom other face this is me in this look
and that look and so it's like the sexy
hot stuff also she has so the the person
on okay I thought well be my is there
gonna be final thoughts oh no this is
just okay maybe let's see how that goes
okay your girl's gonna break the no
nipples fly with no net here your girl's
gonna break the no nipples clause on
Instagram at some point or another
because that's showgirls for you and my
girl has no nipples so she can be sexy
and naked but you don't see any nipple
so she doesn't technically violate it
there's no way for her to also announce
yourself as a robot that's right totally
and no
he would not necessarily break you know
the Turing test buddy yeah but if she's
taking pictures where she's switching
faces and has no nipples why does she
know she's a human okay so because I
asked for pictures hot lifestyle tip and
then like some amazingly interesting
like life hack oh no some upside-down
photo of a shadow or something that just
looks so beautiful as a photograph in
and of itself as she's seeing everything
for the first time in redefining how you
look at the world got it thank you
Darrien okay first of all all of them
though me suppose would have her in it
in some shape waveform even if they went
someone else we know this but she would
all she would never break the note no
nipple rule she's a classy girl okay she
has taste she has standards she told off
Kyle MacLachlan there's a line so there
would be her on a bikini
obviously that's how you get flower
followers that's your bread and butter
you got to post a few of those a week
that's that's what's gonna happen that
any different color is gonna be the same
things are gonna be some designer
specials are gonna be some you know
corporate jobs [ __ ] like that then
she'll also do a little uh you know just
kind of an art piece and because she had
the whole high waisted panties maybe
it'll just be whale tail it'll just be
back you know just various studies of
whale tail people love that that comes
trending back that's a hit and then
something really kind of inspirational
just her at a pond you know thinking
about dancing always you know some you
know something poignant what's the
caption for that one at the pond a
tickle of my toes in the water and then
you'd have to Ben she'd have her million
followers just catching that [ __ ] okay
how she do it and DJ listen first off I
gotta say I'm a little bit uncomfortable
with the amount of objectification going
on in
accounts but let's talk about the photo
spider-man would take one because he's
got that spider drone he's able to take
pictures from whatever so he can go to
the highest spot in New York be hanging
off of his web have a picture of that
and look as you say highest spot in New
York as spider-man boom that's one the
other one is is he's hanging out with
Gamora in space so we find if we want
the hot ladies cool we got a hot alien
green babe in space all right then he
can have a shot of him and the Avengers
using schwarmann just goofing around
hashtag squad goals those are just three
think about all the other awesome
alright let's break this down
you know everybody presented some
interesting choices some iconic movie
characters taking pictures at the
heights of their powers but at the end
of the day you guys just broke down like
two basic Instagram accounts like that
was like some basic ass [ __ ] that you're
described and and they but you but then
at the start of the match though you had
a real strong dig on DJ where you called
out the security possibilities is he
gonna be is he is he gonna lead people
to avengers headquarters or someone
gonna hack his account but you know what
the quality of spider-man's pictures I
mean just from the angles to who he's
hanging out with gotta go points DJ this
is Ray what about Aunt May only May
would die and young
you sold into white slavery lon
once again the fans are with you how 69%
for spider-man on Twitter to 17% for Ava
and 14% for no me I've never seen this
before and I double refresh to make sure
Ava got 0% on YouTube overwhelming for
spider-man there's 71% a man where's all
my Sikander heads were there any facts
factual screw-ups no no there was a lot
of debate no factual scripts there was a
lot of debate about would Spiderman
necessarily being on Instagram mean that
his secret identity was given away
because Jay jonah Jameson's never
figured it out that was a common refrain
that I heard in the chat room well
nobody at the newspapers figured it out
why would the Instagram audience
necessarily figure it out that's a good
point um and you know no offense guys I
listen I follow some booty models a
friend of mine like a girl I was just
like friends with said to me one time
like you like what's up with all of your
likes and I realize that like if someone
wants to get your like so I started
doling out my likes a little with a
little bit more on all the pictures I
like and like I I guess I like I guess I
was on a streak of liking some
scandalous so now I'm a lot more
discerning about my likes Alex you know
what I'm talking about
no I'm not you're talking about that no
your Instagram is scandalous all right
cool
Wow DJ is out in front - Oh unbelievable
have to switch seats with I'm into some
not work to the wise gentlemen let's
step our collective games up all right
you're really gonna regret that's not
even round three promotion for the movie
hit promotion for the upcoming remake of
the Stephen King penned thriller horror
thriller it includes a two story
interactive house in Hollywood
what movie characters house would be the
most fun to visit again
most fun to visit round three Darien
sills Evans were starting with you
this house is a house that I loved since
childhood and who wouldn't want to spend
a night a week it'd be a perfect air B&B
I'm saying pee-wee Herman's house from
pee-wee's big adventure i sweet home
look at that look there it is right
there just full of kitsch in the front
yard and the house makes you breakfast
it's a good point that okay I can go on
but I'll save it for my argument okay
BAM pee-wee pee-wee Herman's house
parents Playhouse but is it different
from different from the Playhouse okay
you know if I'm allowed to include he's
had three houses he's had his Netflix
house he's had his Playhouse and he's
had you know the house from the Warner
Brothers movie okay so they're all
different they're all terrific and they
all beat these two houses all right well
we shall see DJ yes answer I you know
what I had to go I was trying to think
of something other than this but like I
got to stick with my brand you know and
I mean superhero stuff Wayne Manor think
about it cuz not only do you have a
mansion which with all the amenities you
would want to have a mansion multiple
bedrooms classic a library everything
you could ever possibly want in this one
space and then beneath it the secret
lair of one of the greatest
superheroes and the entire world you
have secret switches hidden rooms fire
poles you can slide now that trusts you
up as a superhero you've got some of the
greatest in the cars in the garage and
you've got the best cars in the world
already in the garage and then in the
Batcave you have the Batmobile and a jet
and a boat and a motor cycle that all do
other amazing various amazing things
you've got the greatest computer in the
world you will never get lag ever again
it's got everything it's the perfect
mancave it's the perfect lady cave it's
the Batcave and a mansion on top of it
BAM there you go Wayne Manor Bret
Christian gray Gray's house from Fifty
Shades of Grey not only you have
sweeping view downtown Seattle but it
also has a super-fun sex place and sex
is so fun and weird sex is even funner
than that and so yeah that's where I
would put it a Wayne Manor does not have
a sex dungeon it doesn't know are you
sure it does not have a sex all I'm let
me think are you saying there's nothing
kinky about Batman I'm saying there is
no there is no dedicated zone as we know
and you'd have to be making it up which
is not honorable that has a sex area
with a lot of weird and sex inventions
he has the Batcave of sex and so it was
just double as sex gadgets because of
them he's a multi thinker fight it out
guys all right um but you're both wrong
right okay bring it why well Kristen
Grace plays is a cold horrible place no
one's gonna want to go there
it looks like I'm you know when it looks
like a like a funeral home really you
take out the furniture what is it just
marble everywhere it's a penthouse in
downtown Seattle legless steps from the
place where they throw the fish listen
check out my cold emotionless penthouse
but also don't worry there's a room in
there that makes sex hurt because I'm in
there
in blended way and billions and billions
of women would disagree with you I
really read it out loud sorry trillions
of women which is great a lot of people
read the books I don't know if they'd be
into the room here's the thing uh hi I'm
here to tour stately Wayne Manor Oh an
oak and study what's passed it
Oh another oak paneled study past that
another oak pattern tell me you don't
want a mansion but all would see at
Wayne Manor is the mansion you're not
going to the Batcave tours all the time
he gives them to orphans he gives me
everybody nobody gets to see the Batcave
unless they like drug Alfred or you know
who's to say we don't see the backhand
case is Bruce Wayne dead now and
everyone knows that he's been Batman or
like hear or see where Bruce Wayne
billionaire dad used to be Batman I
would go so far as to say in the
agreement on Airbnb it would explicitly
say no Batcave access the Batcave were
there dot dot dot also here's what's
terrible about the Batcave bats down
like this murky ass terror lair for me
bats all over the place it's dank it's
wet like what do you want here's what
you get after you go to the bat laden
like moisture dungeon you get rabies and
a lung infection well you can this
bachelor from falling those bats are
well managed you've got some of the
greatest cold like you can see the part
where you take say there's a helipad on
the top of Christian Grace thing also
did I mention there's like awesome weird
sex stuff you can do again for everybody
you're not gonna be able to draw you'll
be like oh look there's that anyways for
everybody what's for everyone is
breakfast in the morning when you wake
up via cartoon machinery here's the
thing is that's not even the coolest
house in that movie there's the the
terrible guy who lives down the road has
like the giant indoor swimming pool yeah
but that's not a Francis if we're
assuming that we're not seeing the
Batcave in our Airbnb thing why are we
taking a tour of the sex dungeon because
it's just a door excellent point
there's no what there is is an open wait
a minute wait a minute house play house
or or or just the Airbnb or his third
Netflix house that you can visit and
there's no secrets hears that nobody's
gonna try to kill you or have sex with
you in them it's just beautiful place
we're just gonna give you toys and dude
okay um that makes your teeth black and
stuff like that but it's not going to be
what this Christian Grey do and if
you're not a woman can you even go to
his house yes that is close-minded sir
I'm just saying here's the thing is your
thing is like the most terrifying house
in the universe I don't know I can't
remember what's what but in pee-wee's
house I believe there's like a chair
with a face that's it on that and if you
want to sit on someone's face do it in a
sex dungeon thank you I would much
rather have a friendly cartoon friends
than a sex dungeon that somebody else
uses on the rag yeah that's fine and
okay did you see the wealth in that
man's house I'm sure he has a very
trustworthy cleaning person I feel bad
for those people your house isn't as
cool as iron man's house it's a cooler
or a batwing
copter or a bad motorcycle plane every
suit that he as a suitcase that turns in
tires like some turn out much better
your next points only two Tony Stark's
house would be better than the Bruce not
the best in the category only in the
category and it's the best category sex
layer here's what Wayne Manor has giant
dinosaur robot also a giant penny and
susan armor those innovations
okay okay gentlemen I'd like to hear
your final thoughts and maybe talk to me
a little bit and include in there what a
day at that house would be like okay
Darien you wake up you already smell the
breakfast happily that's wonderful I bet
by now pee-wee's rigged it up so you can
just go along the conveyor belt kind of
Jetson style and your clothes get
changed and you go into a shower and
next thing you know you're sitting there
eating you can watch TV you're going for
right around the block with your bike
play some pranks on people go back home
and then dinner's made via another
machine you're going in Reverse or some
[ __ ] like that that's a day
all right that's a day DJ listen you you
wake up in one of the most opulent
comfortable beds you have ever been in
in your entire life Alfred comes in with
breakfast served you're like this is the
most amazing meal I've ever had you go
downstairs and they're like right this
way sir you press you open Shakespeare's
head and press a button and there's a
fire pole that you slide down you're
dressed as Batman you get to be Batman
for a day all right you're getting to
play around on the back computer you
take the Batmobile for a spin bring it
back Alfred's got dinner made for you
you get to do some more playing on the
back computer try out the Batman armors
say take a ride on the giant robot t-rex
and then go back into that nice comfy
bed all right there is no way that Bruce
Wayne's bed is any more comfortable than
Christian Grey's bed
what's a Sleep Number whatever will
infinity there is no way that Bruce
Wayne's breakfast cooked by English
Alfred is any better they like oh here's
bangers and mash
no Alfred's gonna make terrible
breakfast so my breakfast is better okay
it isn't made by robot I totally smile
you guys and then after that you go to
do some sex stuff
that you've never even imagined so you
do sex stuff for like three or four
hours until you need a break you walk to
Pikes Place Market where they watch
people throw fish
goosh coos it's Seattle and then sex
stuff more sex stuff on infinity number
sleep bed
Wow Wow three vastly different has three
different experiences three potential
vacation brochures so this this was
difficult before we get into it lawn
facts not not really a lot of facts
there was a lot of discussion on Twitter
about is Wayne Manor inherently
depressing because the man who lives
there is so depressed or would it be fun
if you injected some fun energy in there
like you were fun and you were visiting
would that make it more fun also a big
debate does the x-mansion count like it
is Professor X's home but it is also a
school there was a lot of back-and-forth
on that a lot of people really enjoyed
murky asked error layer that has become
a the number one fan suggestion that we
did not discuss Willy Wonka everybody
good I am Willy Wonka probably has a
really fun Houston I wonder if that guy
has a house yeah that was his that was
this factory factory I think they're
just theorizing I bet his house is also
fun I don't know my house is nothing
like where I work well man you guys you
guys made this a difficult choice for me
I mean yeah the Batcave of the Batcave
is awesome but is that inherently part
of Wayne Manor the answer was Wayne
Manor and you said that all the fun
would come from the Batcave and I'm not
sure like I don't think if you if you
freaking air being beat that stuff like
he would not let you know like I think
they made some excellent points they
called you out and I don't think you
properly fielded you know that they're
they're dings on you Brett man the Red
Room huh you're all about that Red Room
I think we learned more about you
and actually learn about the answer to
the question and let me go back to the
question the question was what movie
characters house would be the most fun
to visit I think the key word here is
fun and Darien you painted a fun day
with all of the gadgets the pranks it
would just be a good time as bike you
mentioned the bike you go for a bike
ride in the neighborhood that would be a
fun day
with all the doodads you could the
breakfast would be made for you daddy
until sevens gets the point are you one
[Applause]
once again all about the DJ picks we
matter with 56% on Twitter and 61% on
YouTube pee-wee Herman 31% on Twitter
and 26% on YouTube bringing up the rear
as he enjoys when I guess that was a
toughy where there were there any
comments about whether or not that the
Batcave would be on the table if you
were at Wayne Manor
yeah everybody seemed to agree that the
Beckett was on the table there was a lot
of back-and-forth about like well DJ
mentioned you know like well there's a
huge penny and there was discussion
about like well is that is that really
fun with the back baby fun the back gave
too severe I think was what people sort
of discuss yes yeah bring up a solid
point about just massive chasms that you
could just fall
the phrase again lucky all right we are
moving to round numero four oh man this
is this is a tough question but
gentlemen you are you've come in
prepared with your answers what is the
best comedy of the decade so far best
comedy of the decade so far and it's
question four we are back around to DJ
start us off alright so for me I mean
this is very like I had to pick the one
that made me to laugh the most the one I
remember most the one that stuck with me
the most and it came out just at the
start of the decade and then it has to
be macGruber we can all be honest that
the macGruber sketches were not SNL's
necessarily best
however from that iffy origin they made
not just not just a fantastic SNL movie
but the perfect send up of 80 every 80s
action movie you have ever seen with a
woefully incompetent secret agents that
is probably more dangerous to his own
team than he is to the bad guys but
there's a bunch of great one-liners
bunch of great running gags just just
just a laugh out loud
fantastic movie that I cannot wait for a
sequel for got it DJ goes with macGruber
Bret bridesmaids bridesmaids has the
most iconic scenes the most quoted and
quotable lines and memorable scenes and
then that cast is super stacked and not
only that but it changed comedy it
opened up the world for a female
dominated cast to put out something that
is genuinely funny and enjoyable for a
wide audience when I go to Vegas I play
on the bridesmaid slot machines and it
reminds me how awesome that movie is it
has you know made its way into every
nook and cranny
not only society but Christian Grey sex
layer and that's why I think it is the
best comedy of the decade so far 2011
BAM Brett's gone with bridesmaids daring
souls Evans uh I have to say for me when
I think of uh what comedy stick with me
even for my childhood it's always
something that went off the beaten path
a little bit and for me for this decade
I'm gonna say dope mm-hmm not a movie a
lot of people talk about but uh unlike a
lot of other comedies that have come out
it doesn't have the same convention
that's about a kid in Los Angeles is a
bit of a nerd and gets in over his head
with some drug packages it's an
extremely funny original movie that uh
you know probably deserve a little more
attention and it's very hilarious
excellent alright three very funny
choices three strong choices gentlemen
drop the gloves and go at it macGruber
an SNL movie Wow way to break the mold
there Wow there was a great what a great
accomplishment to go from a one joke
sketch to a functional movie but isn't
bridesmaid just bachelor party
our hangover or hangover hangover - like
the lady's hangover it really is yeah
I'd say both it's not it's not the
funniest movie of the decade it is it is
the best comedy of the decade maybe the
highest news unless that doesn't make it
funny yeah it is funny it is it is
wildly uproariously funny see dip a lot
of different scenes everybody likes that
movie and look at the cast that it has
it introduced us essentially to the box
office and just comedy power and value
of people like Melissa McCarthy Ellie
Kemper Kristen Wiig and then it's
supporting cast just sports all these
amazing people like rebel Wilson Harris
a bunch of people that we're all tired
of seeing exactly
now as it was in 2011 yes I would say
even you know seven years later it
doesn't hold up I would compare the P
scene in your movie - the poop scene in
my movie and the poop scene is funnier
and
remember onok than the pc in your mind
we'll compare that funny it's a really
good movie it's like a good comedy it's
not a great comedy I can compare both
your pee and poop scenes to a scene
whose primary dialogue joke I cannot say
on this show but where macGruber just
wants to know what piece of office
equipment he needs to please to be able
to go on this mission to stop the man
that killed his his wife with a new
partner played by your favorite Kristen
Wiig so you get a lot of that Kristen
Wiig love in this movie before
bridesmaids before she blew up killing
it in this movie oh you guys yeah but so
the question is what do people remember
Kristen Wigg from is it macGruber
no bridesmaid people seeing more making
it better yeah but when I'm looking at
like the great comedies of all time I'm
looking at things that make you laugh
the whole time that are significant in
what they did in the history of comedy
and macGruber to me is just another SNL
movie that is a send-up of a genre and
bridesmaids is like this is the era when
women are allowed to finally have a
chance to define what an era of comedy
looks like now it's about to be fair I
mean that is great and I will not argue
that bridesmaids it's not funny I find
it funny I don't find it as funny as
macGruber but I find it funny but it's
important I don't think it plays into
its funniness and speaking of that I
have to agree with him dope is awesome I
don't know it's like laugh out loud for
me but that's the problem you know that
comedies are what we judges comedies
always have to be these laugh out loud
kind of gross fest where you have the
you know the poop scene which is the
centerpiece of your movie but you know
the pee scene is a very small part of
dope it's about the nuance and nuance
and the long run is funnier in comedy
the comedies that we remember like Young
Frankenstein is not notice because it
has nuance and it makes you think a
little bit more than bridesmaids are you
saying seeing where this badass Rambo
ripoff accidently blows up his own team
doesn't have nuance is that what you're
trying to tell I actually like macGruber
I'm kind of torn cuz I saw that you
picked that how's it going yeah that was
fun I think that where this weird Venn
diagram where it's like I like
bridesmaids I just don't think it's as
funny as macGruber yeah no one's gonna
be like two years from now I think in
that when people look back on comedies
from to the 2010s they're gonna say in
this order
bridesmaids then dope for sure and then
macGruber is just gonna be the way it is
now when you think about it in
conversations like I am a dreamer shirt
incorrect because there are groups of
people I am one of them but I you know
desperately want a sequel for macGruber
right nobody started on a sequel for
bridesmaids or doe I'm waiting for a
sequel for macGruber and I really loved
all his arguments is that if it gets us
like it would want a sequel is it well
you're it made the most money my
argument is not gonna make my argument
is it is a bunch of extremely funny
women in an ensemble comedy that works
from beginning to end right it has heart
that has themes that everybody can agree
with but then tonight just funny when
that I haven't seen girls trip
oh really well what does that say about
you I also didn't see spider-man so I
that was a protester I'd like everybody
right now to take me through the
funniest scene or the scene that made
you laugh the hardest in your movie and
we'll start with Darien oh gosh oh man
so many scenes in in dope fudge good you
can't say that p1 now you can vomit
that's the piezometer table all right
well the p1 any scene with ASAP Rocky it
was pretty funny
and uh and I wasn't expecting him to be
funny I was expecting to be typical
rapper in a movie and he can elevated
the game and and that was that was the
big thing that was a surprise the
stories was a surprise and even the kind
of stunt casting of celebrity turned out
to work you know mm-hmm that's a big win
especially for you know movie that's an
indie that a lot of people aren't gonna
get to see
cool Thank You Darian PJ tell me
something that made you laugh
particularly hard in macGruber it's hard
to my go-to is the scene that I cannot
recite here because it's a little coarse
but there's also where he blows up his
team which is also actually you know
that's what I'm gonna go with it's great
the running gag of burping birthday
amazing but where they go through a
whole montage classic 80s movies montage
where he assembles his team and their
pro wrestlers and athletes these are the
biggest guys these are these are macho
man he assembles them all you see as a
rapport and then he's talking about his
about his plan he's like and we've got
all this dynamite that I packed in the
van with these hands and immediately the
man behind them blows up and this team
of amazing badass people that he picked
up was just destroyed which then leads
right into the other thing which I can
just a little too dirty tour site here
gotcha but funny stuff
Bret mine is a poop scene that isn't too
dirty to recite and that's an
accomplishment so I am torn between the
scene on the plane the scene when she is
you know has to make Duty and they all
get sick yes and Maya Rudolph in the
middle of the street breaking down and
just say or depending on which version
you see every outtake that they recut
and putting the extra features is itself
its own special brand of funny and so I
would have to go with that I mean that
is an iconic scene in addition to
everything else is this the final
thought
go ahead go right into your final
thoughts and my final thought is your
movie is really good but it's not like
as funny as bridemaids or macGruber
yours it's it is a send-up of a moot
point like it is it works on nostalgia
to a group of people that like that but
that's not really like those things that
are at work with 80s action movies
weren't really at work making the
problems it wasn't like doing anything
that important it was just another SNL
movie that had funny moments and was
fine but mine is one that is important
and made millions and millions of people
laugh no matter who you were
and that's why I think that it is the
number one movie not to mention its
higher rate at the moment great
background for final thoughts that sucks
okay no dope is going to be remembered
when when when when they teach comedy
and film classes dope will be remembered
you know bridesmaids will not and
macGruber actually might be I feel like
bridesmaids will be remembered because
like you said that it gave all of these
the world these great comedians and it
also made a lot of money but in the end
I don't know the movies kind of
derivative of so many other kind of bro
movies and that was kind of the anti
boom I don't know maybe it's apparent I
don't really have a lot of bridesmaids
but I'm with I'm gonna stick with dope I
think it's it's gonna it's gonna it's
gonna stand the test of time
thank you sir DJ ELISA I again macGruber
is though only one of these movies that
that people were passionate enough loved
enough that they actually still want a
sequel for this movie they're still
asking for it I think it took a small
concept and did so many things with it
not just for the schedule was not just
being an SLR movie not just being a
setup for action movies but making
something new and fun and when he has
the notebook filled with with the the
guy that cuts him off at the beginning
of the movie just so many great running
gags that really pay off so much great
comic energy and it just makes me smile
thinking about it alright Wow three
funny movies but a deadly unfunny
argument
[Laughter]
entertaining but it's just dumb blood
back because it's a fight you're both
you're all three very entertaining
gentlemen one what's the internet saying
there's a lot of discussion about does
best comedy mean funniest comedy or
doesn't mean best movie that could be
categorized the comedy dopes not being
sort of laugh out loud but being maybe a
better quality movie really through a
lot of people also a lot of debate we
should clarify by current decade we
meant 2010 to now yes a lot of people
are thinking do we mean 2007 would
hangover super bad or movies in that
little end of the last decade but we
were saying 2010 to 2017 just to clarify
yes and a lot of the other some really
great movies and the people suggest
these Deadpool came up a lot and came up
an awful lot 21 Jump Street came up a
lot pop star lego movie wolf of Wall
Street and then Dark Horse Suicide Squad
a lot of people Wall Street would we
call that a comedy a lot of funny scenes
but you know right is it a comedy scene
alright so uh yeah so the arguments the
decision here Wow you guys you did you
did come to play I'm really happy
daring that you brought up dope because
I feel that movie is you know doesn't
get as much love as it should because it
had its own tone and it wasn't afraid to
try different things and be a little bit
experimental in the storytelling and the
filmmaking and I really love that movie
I don't think you quite sold me enough
on why it would have been the best
comedy yeah but yeah and I and I love
all the young actors in the film and
ASAP Rocky was good and I love seeing
Chanel Iman and that one scene I follow
her on Instagram
but let's came down to these two
gentlemen for me and your passion DJ was
really selling me on macGruber but I
feel like Brett cut it down a little bit
by calling it just putting in a box and
calling it an SNL movie and a genre
send-up and we didn't really have combat
that and when we think about best comedy
of a decade so far taking into account
the humor and he mentioned things like
the cast introduced like so many of our
preeminent comedy stars right now and it
did change comedy you would not have
girls trip he mentioned that in his
opening thing which I saw is very funny
and bad moms and so many other movies
that are doing well and this kind of
opened that portal into the under good
portal it's a good portal and you sold
me on bridesmaids break at the point 69
percent on YouTube for bridesmaids and
47 percent on Twitter at one both bulbs
69 all right Wow so we are going
function we are going into round number
five and it is DJ and the lead was to
Bret with one Darian with one it's any
man's ball game here's your question who
would be the worst possible actor to
cast as James Bond the worst bond we all
know we have opinions about who we'd
like to take over for bond but who would
be the worst and fifth round Brett we
are starting with you Roseanne I just
think that it's a mix of Wow
nice try but uh yeah Roseanne is a mix
that image is amazing it's like the
temptation here is to pick like the
person that's so bad that you'd have to
see you know you might fall into the
trap of someone who's so bad that you
have to kind of see it
Roseanne has just kind of been not
making comebacks for years she's like
occasionally and she's like in an
episode of the offices like Andy's
manager so she's just like this nothing
that there is no reason at all to pick
Roseanne as James Bond if you did that
it would be just like unimpressive Lee
eh
huh and that is where I want us all to
live and I think that is the ultimate
definition of the worst actor to pick
for a movie
Roseanne all right coming out guns
blazing with Roseanne Wow Darian I went
with someone British because bond would
have to be British unless he was George
Lazenby right but they would the worst
British person that could play Bond
there's someone who isn't really even
acting anymore so they have to come out
of retirement like Sean Connery did to
play Bond and that would be Russell
Brand oh look at that he kind of looks
good there actually his handsome
I see just put anybody that poses like
you know what nobody likes him he's kind
of too obnoxious to be bond and even if
he tried to like play it cool and clean
up his act that kind of smug you know it
all this would come through and you know
this bond would be you know way above
like sleeping with chicks but then he'd
sleep at all the chicks anyway and then
berate them for being too stupid you're
welcome yeah yeah Russell Brand that's
my guy
got it Russell Brand DJ yes talk to me
uh you know I was thinking the worst
bond would have to not be British
because obviously you want him to be
British so so if you were to go with a
worse bond
be American he should somebody be
somebody that doesn't have any of the
suave debonair characteristics he should
somebody that doesn't necessarily have
the physical action chops honestly
somebody that's bad this is actually
after I quite enjoy just not at all does
not fit at all into this role and that's
Seth Rogen he's lovable he's affable
he's the picture of that I'm like no
it's he doesn't even work even Roseanne
I was kind of yeah maybe
besides Roseanne something he's not a
fun that talented performer he's
fantastic he's just he's American he
doesn't I just he's not a Ladykiller
he's not a killer killer he doesn't have
any of the characteristics he would
undercut everything that makes bond bomb
as he's trying to be bomb and so I think
he would completely dismantle the
character so Seth Rogen was involved in
an international hacking scheme that
revolved around the murder of the North
Korean I really want you to interview
actually if I'm being honest and I'm
saying that if I described not only the
interview the plot of the interview
which is essentially a spy movie so he's
already proven he can do a good spy
movie and just everything that erupted
around it he's already a secret agent
but listen Melissa McCarthy was in a
good spy movie she wouldn't make a good
bond
yeah or enemy I think she would make a
better bond as would Seth Rogen than
Roseanne because Seth Rogen is charming
and bond is charming so I'm picking such
engine was charming enough to be hired
for Green Hornet yeah but he bombed that
movie that was the closest movie he's
ever done spawn I get it did bomb almost
as bad as if they put Roseanne is the
Green Hornet right I'm just saying she's
not and also you guys both have movie
stars and they have Russell Brand a
movie star Forgetting Sarah Marshall
he's really good and Forgetting Sarah
Marshall is pretty good but he's in both
yeah and
is British you already got one thing
right which makes them one step better
than these other chips that doesn't mean
he won't be the worst
he's totally obnoxious two and a half
hours of Russell Brand saving the world
that's that's not a movie gentlemen walk
me through how your character would tank
a classic bombed moment take a moment
and think about it how would your
character maybe give us a little bit of
it the impression of the character as
well I'd like to hear maybe a little bit
of that your character really just nose
into the tarmac on something that's
classically bond and Brett were going to
start with you
vodka martini shaken not stirred wow
that was pretty horrific sorry you know
the I mean mission accomplished that was
off-putting yeah like gross and just
became the clubhouse leader all right
and that's uh great Darion I don't drink
I don't even do British license I don't
drink so could I have a seltzer and you
know that if you do drink you're just a
puppet of the corporate people want you
to drink you should read about in my
book boom Russell Brand will be shilling
first as James Bond DJ walk us through a
Seth Rogen bar I want you to think of
any Bond action scene I'll give you a
specific one but really any will do
let's think about the famous foot chase
scene at the beginning Casino Royale
so probably probably the best Bond movie
one of the best Bond movies and I'd like
to you to try and imagine at all Seth
Rogen doing that sequence where bond has
to run up by construction site to chase
anybody and it's just and again also
think about Green Hornet came in
but then but then put that to a
character that people actually care
about today
let's get final thoughts okay um what
are my final thoughts roses so both of
you guys are movie stars and I think
they're both since there's comedians who
are still around and have done stuff
more recently everyone would be able to
or at least some people would be able to
see some kind of satirical approach to
this so if you saw Seth Rogen bumbling
through this like dumb stumbling through
James Bond situations it would be
possible to think of it as a satire
Russell Brand is a is a is a you know
you don't like him and a lot of people
don't like him but I love him and
Forgetting Sarah Marshall as that suave
charming like gorgeous man or whatever
you know so Roseanne on the other hand
is a television star who's just kind of
been there I've been kind of floating
around running for president maybe there
is zero reason and I like Roseanne I
think I follow her on Twitter but there
is no reason whatsoever nor any way to
look at her on screen and James Bond and
find a single redeeming quality whereas
you're describing your people that Venn
diagram overlaps more at least once or
twice thank you sir darienne's hills
evans i mean my pic was made with the
idea of that if we were in a real
situation and we were looking for the
new bond he would have to be British and
let's say Russell Brand agents decided
to clean him up and say hey let's give
this a real shot in a crazy world he
could screen test as a great bond and
then get all the way to production but
then still be the worst bond I tried to
think of the realistic possibility of of
the worst possible British movie star
out there so I stand by my choice
because if you clean him up he cleans up
well we saw his picture women do love
him he does he is charismatic but as the
lead in a Bond movie no way thank you
sir DJ you know thinking about the worst
it's just it's just one of those like
Concannon like if you if you to make it
the worst possible bond making
Eric and make it somebody that just does
not have the the skills that you would
look for in any bomb that would just
defuse any action sequences any any
betting the most attractive women in the
entire planet and against the program is
a talented performer but I just think he
would be everything we don't want a Bond
movie Wow
I don't want to see any of them really
like well done picking terrible bonds
lon
well what did one fact there was it was
thrown up at George Lazenby is the only
not English bond as Sean Connery
Scottish he's not English but it was
like well I figured that bond would be
English
technically Connery sky know what's
lazon B's country of Australian and
British so it wasn't alright yeah the
Isles of British Isles you know what
listen
fact check the fact check that's fine
big moment in the YouTube chat room
Brett's impression lit up the room there
were references to maybe of being a
knockout blow I don't want to a lot of
enthusiasm for Brett saw it take on
Roseanne as bond some of the other
suggestions Adam Sandler came up a whole
bunch Michael Cera people seem to feel
would be a terribly sad there would be
good cuz he could go undercover as James
Bond and Tommy Wiseau
oh hi
oh hi I'm you guys you guys did a
wonderful job of presenting terrible
choices they I like that you kept it in
the British parameters because it's like
oh yeah what would the actual casting be
but they they knocked you down a little
bit with the fact that he cleans up well
and he is like a wat he has been a
watchable actor and yeah
and DJ Seth Rogen he has proven to be
charming before and he has been cast as
an unaccustom'd asplenia beg you sweat
delay that was a knockout blow
Bret you get the point I totally get be
like the bad feeling you get when it's
almost right right and then it's wrong
like that is that was a real strong play
at the end all right so at the end of
round five going into the speed round DJ
has to Bret has to darien man I applaud
you this is your first time on yeah no
wonderful choices and strong strong
opinions on arguments but I do need your
help right now I'm gonna ask you and
lawn and Alex for your opinions as we go
into this is the time that tries men's
souls and women's the speed round the
speed round today
horses ride okay so let me go over the
rules this is chance to earn five more
points to win the game the panelists
with the lowest points is automatically
and out here's how it works I will ask a
question we're looking for the fastest
answer and follow-ups on an either-or
question if two players choose the same
answer
the player who said it first gets to
argue for that answer the other player
will have to argue for a different
answer
the player who answers first gets 20
seconds to answer the second also gets
20 seconds and then each person gets a
ten second rebuttal makes sense all
right it's really difficult I always
screw up so let's play some speed rounds
okay first question you have to commute
to work every day with one movie
character who do you pick Iron Man
Superman Iron Man and Superman
we heard Iron Man first can we get 20
seconds on the clock for Brett the clock
starts as soon as you start speaking
Iron Man you can either drive a really
cool car or fly up on the back of a
really cool suit also Iron Man is
freaking fun and amazing and awesome and
drunk and it hasn't killed him yet and
he has drivers and so you just have
someone that's around who has access to
so many assets that can take you there
in an awesome way a different way every
morning and I don't need this time take
it away
okay great rebuttal
listen Superman can also fly you there
he can fly faster than Iron Man so he
can get you to work on time also
Superman cares about you Iron Man cares
about himself so Superman will get you
work on time he will worry about taking
care of you on the way there he might
even get you donuts you can hear about
his amazing stories about saving the
world all across the universe as you get
to work like
ten-second rebuttal I don't need to go
that fast I just swallowed bugs harder
and then super bees are so boring
there's nothing about him and all these
stories are gonna be stupid and I'm not
gonna want donuts because his body is so
good it's gonna make me feel fat okay
you will be safely Superman he doesn't
drink and fly so you don't have to worry
about any of the hazards of getting
there I don't even know if I remain can
really carry people my car in his suit
we haven't really seen him carry people
around we know Superman's gotcha okay
Wow alright alright time time time damn
alright a DC Marvel battle Darian what
are your thoughts on this on this
argument iron man yeah he has carried
people we care about 13 people falling
out of a plane so I think I don't know
might be more fun with Iron Man more
dangerous now so you're going with DJ
yeah okay
oh wait long I think I got a go with
Brett on this one too I think
Superman's not as interesting a
character as Tony Stark he's gonna be
more entertaining on the way and yeah
we've seen them both commute people they
can carry both gay people so I think I
gotta go Iron Man yeah Alex any thoughts
I think both are really good choices but
I think I heard better things about Iron
Man so I'd have to go with bread on this
one yeah this so Superman I start to win
me over when you're talking about how he
cares about getting you there on time
but I think Brent had a little too much
and one thing I really like Tony Stark
has some badass cars as well and he
mentioned the cars and so if you don't
feel like flying that morning you can
jump in but uh the tests with a Maserati
you your choice we're going with Iron
Man bread that's the point
showing work on time with somebody whose
main characteristic is he's a drunk
house it killed him yet oh thanks to the
luck we are gonna need it
all right
second question better
Malhar adaptation Kingsman or kick-ass
okay yes I think you started first dude
I think I heard okay DJ you have
kick-ass and Bret you have the Kingsmen
DJ you'll be going first the clock
begins when you speak this is actually
about something positive about the idea
of becoming better about overcoming your
difficulties
Kingsman is actually kind of gross if
you think about what it's really about
and like the message it ends on and so
kick-ass subverts the thing that it's
about where Kingsman dives in and kind
of makes it grosser
that doesn't sound weird Kingsman I want
to go to that place and be in that world
more than I want to be in the kick-ass
world kick-ass world's so dour and dark
and those kids frighten me and whereas I
want to be part of enjoying and living
in that world with the Kingsmen plus I'd
rather have as a teacher climb and the
difficulties in in in kick-ass they're
just too raunchy for my tastes
ten-second rebuttal to keep us on an
anal joke and get a great subversion of
the superhero world and a great look at
becoming a teacher and actually trying
to do that but also you get Nicolas Cage
for some reason 10 seconds Brett you can
take your nickel is Cajun keep him and
earlier I proposed sex dungeon so I'm
fine with an anal joke and in addition
to that kick-ass I didn't like okay time
Darien thought oh this is tough these
are both really great I have to say when
you said I'd like to be in that world
more I think Kingsman is a is a safer
more fantastic world to be in than kick
ass which can be quite brutal and sad
okay thank you sir lon thoughts I
personally really prefer Kingsman as a
movie but I think DJ had a much stronger
argument on behalf of kick-ass I gotta
go with kick-ass yeah Alex anything to
add no I totally agree I think just as a
movie I think I like Kingsman more but I
think DJ just had like a stronger
argument with kick-ass and yes I got to
get to him yeah yeah DJ I feel like your
opening salvo painted the picture of the
interpretations of these two films and
why yours is superior and that was not
overcome by Bret DJ you get the point
yeah I don't remember Kingsman as much
as I remember kick-ass searching stuff
oh all right we are we are we are
deadlocked at four apiece correct or
three apiece three three three pieces
yes we are deadlocked at three three it
is hot in here all right I got the
vapors next speed round question
question number three who is the worst
character from the new Star Wars
franchise force awakens in rogue one the
worst character Gleason's one Captain
phasma Captain phasma domhnall gleeson
general hux thank you all right Captain
phasma
general Hux Bret you spoke first 20
seconds begins whenever you speak
there is absolutely no nuance water
whatsoever to this character it's just
Donald Gleeson doing an impression of
like a nasally British person and it and
their Enys just so whiny and there is
nothing to it it's just like ill you all
so terrible I haven't like anything that
you've done this is an impression of
things I vaguely remember people doing
when I was 17 watching the original Star
Wars Snoke poked me Captain phasma
represents everything that's wrong with
the Star Wars franchise now and that she
is just a cool costume they hired one of
the best actresses we have who can do
amazing stuff on game thrones and she
doesn't do anything except get beating
around we didn't learn anything from
Boba Fett of a character that just looks
cool but does not
do anything in the plot at all rebuttal
I'd rather have someone that does
nothing than someone who absolutely
annoys me in a role with so much damn
potential this is the person who runs
the baddies essentially and he just
gives us nothing there is no nuance okay
he's given something to do he's able to
yell at kylo Ren he's got a function
captive as Captain phasma literally
exists to sell toys all right Wow strong
on both sides daring where you land on
this I have no idea who Captain phasma
is correct it's like she may know her as
chrome trooper exactly that's all she
has she hasn't served any purpose in a
story I have to go with you okay that's
one for DJ along thought these were both
really strong arguments on behalf of two
characters that I agree are pretty weak
great great great choices yes it's a
tough one but you know I feel like I
just heard a little bit more from Brett
about the lameness of general Hux and DJ
sort of had the one point about you know
Captain phasma didn't get to do very
much so I feel like I got to give it to
prep a slight only slight edge I agree I
think you don't know either the
characters well enough yet but I think
we know a little bit more or there's
more to like about Captain phasma and I
think Brett really brought a lot to the
table of why Huck's is kind of a lame
character so I got to give it to Brett
yeah I thought Brett had a good opening
salvo but then I thought I'm DJ more or
less matched him with strong points but
Brett's impression and via and annoying
us here at the table with his voice as
opposed to hey I didn't know much about
Boba Fett I don't know much about
Captain phasma but I still think they
look pretty sick but your that you're so
annoying you get the point my power
that's been my power today for three
Brett and we are going to question
number four in the speed round
so this is this is must-win for DJ DJ
yes you need to take this point
otherwise Brett goes home a champion a
winner gentlemen which would you rather
see Joe Dante's gremlins 3 or James
Cameron's aliens 3 3 we said different
yeah you said different things who do we
hear first I think I think I heard who
said Cameron listen cam I think I heard
Brett first I'd go in that because I
could tell okay
so Brett you're arguing for James
Cameron's alien 3 and DJ you have Joe
Dante's gremlins 3 Bret year you go
first since we heard you first 20
seconds begins when you speak James
Cameron delivers a world to us in a more
complete way than anyone really has been
able or at least the other guy has been
able to do and also I want to see him
back in action doing something that I
walk away from the way I did from Avatar
saying like here are like themes that I
understand and people I understand in
worlds that are created in ways that are
unprecedented technologically and
immersively alien has been done to death
Cameron is not the same filmmaker
anymore he's gone into Avatar Titanic
land he wouldn't give us the same movie
and also aliens aliens is perfect the
way it is gremlins there's still so much
potential all the ideas they introduced
in gremlins 2 could be explored gremlins
3 we've never got any more grounds after
groans - there's still so much more we
could do nobody else has touched it it's
untapped territory that I would love to
see how they could expand from gremlins
1 to gremlins 2 dramas 3 Bret bigger
longer more ridiculous in gremlins 3
it's just I that is if you argued
earlier it's just a way to sell toys
gremlins story will just become another
way to sell toys or it's not gonna get
better than it was in gremlins 1 I
disagree I think there's so many
different opportunities that the
Plata soar can go through so many
different permutations where aliens we
clearly can't do better because we
haven't done better there's been four
movies since and and she's killing him
alright Alex tell us what you think
I honestly think bream lens is fine
right where it's at well I think back in
the eighties but I think personally just
based on the arguments I think I got to
go with Brett on this one I think that
James Cameron still has a lot of
potential to give us something great
and I'd really like to see him go back
to it thank you sir well on thoughts
yeah dj1 this one I really like the
argument about you know aliens sort of
is this perfect capper to the series and
yet gremlins is like it was different
both times there's so much that has a
bit explore with those characters so I
feel like I got to go DJ Darren I have
to go DJ as well I I really I'm not even
a gremlins fan but you know the thing
about aliens is you know it's kind of
it's been done to death and then there's
so much more to explore with rebels
right now yeah I thought Brett had a
good opening salvo but then I thought DJ
just ripped it up dinging James Cameron
and talking about the potential the
untapped potential of gremlins
and that felt like a knockout blow to me
DJ gets to point and we're all tied up
got beat by gremlins
alright I love gremlins that's a really
good choice he's basically perfect okay
here is the final question what movie
villain has the all-time most fiendish
plan what movie villain has the all-time
most fiendish plan gone girl
the lady gone girl
Ava in you know ex machina Wow those are
definitely two choices
girls I gotta see alright so we heard
about the though I'll go with how he
presented it the lady from gone girl
first Rosamund Pike correct and you'll
be arguing for for Ava and ex machina
yet again yes okay DJ you'll be going
first
twenty seconds begins when you speak
listen world ending the world is
hypothetically scary but I never left a
fear more terrified than leaving gone
girl I felt like I needed to apologize
to every woman in my life
the idea of spoilers faking your own
murder blaming your husband on it the
the diabolical way she puts together the
way she's one step ahead of illiterate
everybody around her in lethal ways is
believable terrifying
Bret whenever you're ready Ava's plot
more directly relates to the downfall of
all humanity by appealing to people's
optimism as opposed to things that
they've done that are potentially
hurtful the people who are in gone girl
who get victimized are themselves
partially guilty because of their
actions Donald Gleeson is not he's just
an innocent guy who believes in love and
that's more diabolical
it's not gonna kind of diffuses itself
by making her villain it doesn't decide
that she's a villain until the very end
she doesn't really have a plan except I
guess screw humanity where as gone girls
all about the diabolical plan that
Rosamund Pike puts into motion yours is
just another scorned lover this one has
more wide-ranging implications about
humanity and this in its more diabolical
because you go more afraid of what she's
going to do next and is it you that she
loves and that's the ambiguity okay
well argued well argued gentlemen Darion
where do you land on this this is tough
I uh I really like DJs argument that you
know what
pikas in gone girl is diabolical just by
human nature she's planning something
you know and Ava is she kind of gets
there by accident proven at the end sure
long yeah the job of arguing the
implications of what Ava does could be
more destructive but the question is
really about like whose plan is the more
fiendish and I really feel like a me and
gone girls much more of a feed and it's
a more diabolically clever plan so I
think I gotta give the edge to teach it
but they were both great artists sure
Alex any thoughts over there uh I
actually haven't seen gone girl right
thank you well I think DJ had a really
good argument but I think the idea of
Brett talking about just artificial
intelligence just being vengeful towards
humanity to me that sounds a lot more
terrifying but I think I agree with that
argument yeah you know the full
wide-ranging plan it did kind of sneak
up on us in ex machina and we don't know
do we even know her full plan I feel
like there's definitely something
there's some interesting territory there
but as far as like really hammering the
question the most fiendish plan the most
diabolical as he said DJ gets the point
and he takes a good day
[Applause]
all of you want any thoughts on the
internet on
oh wow they had a lot of thoughts on
diabolical villains shock the Emperor
Palpatine
at no point came up his plan involves
destroying entire plan like world
destroy yeah okay you know when you're
under these hot lights it was such a
wide open yes jumped in we're like I
guess we'll talk about it and after the
fight I was thinking like scarecrow is
just like terrorizes you with your own
fears but you also wanted to poison the
yeah poison everybody but a lot of
people also for a Joker came up a lot
but then people right but he doesn't
really have a plan he's just kind of
like those open anyone's a rough in the
moment
Thanos well I guess we'll learn the know
if you want MCU Villa and Baron Zemo
came up as I could diabolic yes oh yeah
pick those guys against each other yeah
but um well fought you guys deejay
congratulations you are walking out of
here a victor tell everybody where they
can find you and what you have going on
you can find the ndj talks trash
everyplace that matters or my podcasts
only stupid answers everywhere the
podcasts are listened to we are going to
do a live stream of the entire run of
defenders this Saturday at 9:00 a.m. on
rift TV slash only stupid answers for
the first and last episode if you want
the rest of the episodes check out our
patreon at patreon.com slash only stupid
answers that sounds awesome a lot of fun
out rhetoric my social media handles are
all brett erlich twitter is for just
really topical political humor Instagram
is for pictures of my cat that looks
like a lion and then snapchat is for
tasteful nudes and then watch
youtube.com slash pop trigger and you
jicama slash The Young Turks very cool
thank you sir and Darian sells evans I
can follow my social media to see where
I'm going to be performing comedy
I also do a podcast called race man and
I just directed a movie Oh
congratulations
it's called one bedroom nice Congrats
man and thank you for making your movie
fights a debut I loved it LAN anything
to plug just yeah you can find me on
twitter at ello and as it is it's very
political it gets political on me yeah I
mean those are the times we live in and
Alex yeah I'm also on Twitter moose
buddy 89 you could catch me on there
just jump it in on conversations or in
movie fights and just all other screen
drinky stuff but yeah that's pretty much
why I created thanks thank you guys from
the cooler who is moose buddy 69 and I
am Hal Rudnick you can hit me up Hal
Rudnick on Twitter and Instagram and
check out today's screen junkies show
that went live where we get you caught
up with all four of the Marvel Netflix
series in preparation for the defender
so you can go in there and just binge
the hell out of that stuff you guys
great fights today Andy and everybody's
screen junkies thank you for letting me
take the wheel today and I had such a
blast thanks again to lon and Alex and
all you guys and thank you for watching
bye bye
thanks again to t-mobile for sponsoring
today's episode check out what makes
them America's best unlimited network at
t-mobile comm slash coverage
[Music]
you